all is forgiven to Warren for the venom
two trailer news and yes a lot of other
people did report on it as well so he's
not to blame anyhoo I wanted to watch
this video from The Cosby Wonder the
Fantastic Four casting John's presence
key officially met with Marvel Studios
now before eighty one gift or pennies in
a bunch
a lot of people on Twitter read another
source I've seen other movie sites
report on this as well I just like the
speculation and the reasoning that warm
provides close riff on his video don't
be wrong again warned yeah I'm doing
everybody its warned welcome back to my
channel where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course the MCU today we
have some very exciting news as John
Krasinski has met with Marvel Studios
about an upcoming project now of course
as mostly everybody knows why you should
check out our video and his wife Emily
Blunt in real life to play Sue Storm The
Invisible Woman of the Fantastic Four as
well and Steve Carell to play the family
pretty coy about any type of involvement
with Marvel Studios we have reports that
both of them have now met with Marvel
Studios about upcoming bad sinski
himself even teased the Fantastic Four
in one of his latest YouTube episodes
and a personal story has told me that he
is checked with some of his people and
it seems like John Krasinski as mr.
fantastic is almost a sure thing however
John Krasinski possibly playing a
character in the MCU and we're going to
dive into every single thing that you
need to know about this report and about
what's happening with John Krasinski and
Emily better be good all this talk man
better be good is pretty much close
seeing as how most of their projects
have been put on hold due to the corona
virus but apparently they are not
completely closed as it has been
forted that John Krasinski has met with
some people at marvel studios via zoom
meeting and this could mean a whole
lotta means we can hack in possibly
taking on the roles of mr. fantastic and
The Invisible Woman and possibly
directing a very big future Marvel
Studios film and number one is this like
math or two from the geeks
the report says Marvel hasn't shut down
completely due to the pandemic the
studio has been taking virtual meetings
with various actors writers and
directors over the past weeks and one of
those people is none other than John
Krasinski now on the surface this should
mean a slight slew of things
John Kaczynski has stated before that he
would like to work with Marvel Studios
and Kevin Feige and Kevin Feige has
stated that he would like to work with
John Krasinski in a recent interview
John stated that he would love to work
with Marvel he said I would love to do
it I think to be a part of the Marvel
world would be amazing anyway and the
fact that people would even consider me
for that level of a part would be
amazing now at the time that he stated
this he had not had a spider-man hint he
has and this comes at a very very
interesting time and that is because of
the second thing that you need to know
about John Krasinski possibly playing
mr. fantastic and that is that he
actually has teased this and he did it
on Sunday for those of you who may not
know John Krasinski during this pandemic
has recently started a YouTube channel
the channel has been a pretty big
success and the photo is just such
meteor that he did it has an actual
channel train tunnel and in his episode
on Sunday he teased a plane a comic book
hero and finally there's this four panel
er which I have to appreciate and it'll
be the closest I ever get to playing a
comic book hero
[Music]
now of course he's talking about I'm a
fan art of him obviously there is a real
[Laughter]
cast and of course immediately after he
says that's the closest he'll get to
playing a comic superhero but he
immediately gives us a very interesting
look now clearly if he was in talks to
play mr. fantastic or any other Marvel
character he would not be able to say
but that look definitely implies that
he's up to something and then we get the
report a day later that he's met with
Marvel Studios and this is more than
just a coincidence especially if you
consider the third thing that you need
to know which is that his wife and miss
Perez
also met with Marvel Studios about a
role in the MCU that was several eyes
when we blend every family's Jungle
Cruise her movie coming out with the
rock also a Disney movie which Disney
owns Marvel she met with Marvel Studios
now we don't really know much about
anything that happened during this
meeting besides the fact that it was to
talk about an upcoming project that
Marvel Studios was working on but that
now means that Marvel Studios has met
with both Emily Blunt and her husband
John Krasinski and there's no doubt that
Marvel Studios knows that the fans want
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt to play
mr. fantastic and The Invisible Woman
and it's very clear by John Kruse in
Cambodia plus interviews that he's done
that he knows fans want him to play that
as well and that brings us to the fourth
thing that you need to know that comes
from a report from Mikey Sutton and this
is what Mikey had to say even though
countless fans have been growing up
social media to have John Krasinski in
the role that doesn't mean that the
studios will listen
however several insiders have told Mikey
Sutton that Krasinski is in serious
negotiations for mr. fantastic as for
his wife Emily Blunt who would make the
perfect Invisible Woman that is still up
in the air as she apparently isn't
interested in what a lengthy contract
would be however sources have told
Mikey's my husband and apparently Marvel
Studios is interested in Krasinski
beyond his acting abilities and are
actually looking at him to direct aim
Marvel Studios film which we'll talk
about in number five number four is that
the timing of all of this seems to
really line up I thought I didn't it was
long and I'm a new MCU Fantastic Four to
make their debut in ant-man 3 along with
this Paul Rudd also wrote an entire
script that included a modock in it
apparently now moved away from this idea
and are thinking about including the
Young Avengers in the film but they were
planning on introducing the Fantastic
Four but instead of them actually having
a pretty major role in the movie they'll
probably now be teased in the film which
means we can probably expect an actual
Fantastic Four movie to come out right
around then if not too long after and
Marvel Studios does have a tendency to
pick actors for roles before actual
scripts are done and before directors
are chosen for example they cast Maher
saleh ali way before anything for blade
has been done including script or
casting no directors no writers no one
but a terrible choice terrible what has
he done Captain Marvel they cast brie
Larson way before they had a director
and Kevin Feige did mention about blade
when asked why blade why now he said
because of Maher Saleh Ali so perhaps
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt are just
the perfect cast for mr. fantastic and
The Invisible Woman that they fit so
perfectly for the movie to come out
however the last thing you need to know
coming in at number 5 is that John
Krasinski could very well be directing a
Marvel Studios films yes everybody wants
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt to play
mr. fantastic and The Invisible Woman
of course Marvel Studios knows this and
of course they'll take this into
consideration but just because they may
cast them as characters in the MCU
doesn't mean that they can't also have
John Krasinski direct an MCU film John
Krasinski has recently gotten into
directing and he said that he would be
up for directing a Marvel Studios film
and that brings us to the second half of
Mikey's report and he says that Marvel
Studios is apparently interested in John
Krasinski beyond his acting abilities
they are considering him to direct and
also possibly write it in a Fantastic
Four movie however that's not all
apparently there was talk about
Krasinski being considered to direct to
additional Marvel Studios film while
Severson mag Suns movie which would have
a new MCU take on Ghost Rider if blade
is a hit and
the next Captain America movie although
it's unknown who will carry the shield
as of right now interest in directing a
future Marvel movies but as far as mr.
fantastic ghosts they are focused on
getting John Krasinski nailed down for
the role of Reed Richards aka mr.
fantastic for his Fantastic Four debut
which we have word could be before the
actual Fantastic Four team debuts as
reported before Marvel Studios
apparently wants the Illuminati to
appear in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and if you're not
aware of who the Illuminati are they're
a group consisting of the sorcerer
supreme Doctor Strange Black Bolt the
king of the Inhumans Charles Xavier the
founder of the x-men of course Namor the
Submariner the king of Atlantis Iron Man
himself and of course mr. fantastic of
the Fantastic Four now obviously there's
going to be a different iteration of
this considering that we no longer have
Iron Man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but with the Fantastic Four
coming into the MCU not roading from now
and Krasinski being hide for mr.
fantastic it would make sense that he
would appear in the Illuminati and then
from there go on to be a mentor to
spider-man let's not forget the big
building that went up during spider-man
a far from home there's a lot of
speculation that it could be the but the
Marvel Studios and Disney themselves
don't have the rights to Norman Osborn
but they do have the rights now to the
Fantastic Four so it would make more
sense that this is going to be the
Baxter building whatever the future
heads the Fantastic Four are definitely
coming to the MC if Kevin Feige himself
has mentioned this at San Diego
comic-con of 2019 and it's appearing as
if fans may get what they want with John
Krasinski plane mr. fantastic and it
really does seem like John Krasinski
could have teased this on his YouTube
channel as well and if he comes then
it's more than likely his wife Emily
Blunt will come as the Invisible Woman
but let me know what you think about all
of this new information that we got
today leave a like if you'd like John
Krasinski to play mr. fantastic of the
Fantastic Four
also don't forget to subscribe to stay
up to date on everything relating to the
fence so close to 550,000 always thank
you all so much for watching
Warren
like joggers this skis got a really move
this seems like warm put a lot more
information in here to back up the
reasoning for doing this video this is a
very well researched piece oh yes I
can't have that venom to crap go down
again have this ruin my reputation funny
isn't that last slide he showed of the
construction from spider-man far from
home of what might be the Baxter
building you know that little banner
that he highlighted had a 1 a 2 a 3 and
then it kind of extended on to the
future you know under script that said
we can't wait to show you what comes
next so maybe that's a direct reference
to that the number four comes next
that's an easter egg breakdown that's a
new rock stars moment okay I think the
pandemic is actually in some ways good
for Marvel Studios right now because the
ability to miss Marvel hahahaha Marvel
the ability to long for Marvel who wants
a more Marvel yearn for Marvel that
feeling anticipation I think we've
gotten so used to seeing Marvel Buffy
you know it's gonna be another movie
another one
even after endgame there was spider-man
is like oh I guess Black Widow is
getting a movie now now I think the
anticipation factor is even higher so
they can do all this bill being up in
the zeitgeist simmering of anticipation
wanting more
it's so like with all these reports
whether these leaks and stuff are real
or completely false all it's doing is
aiding in wanting more Marvel okay now
all it's doing is helping their pilot
really is so when they're finally able
to come back whether it be Disney Plus
show or Black Widow that does stick to
its release date schedule anything or
any trailer or footage of whatever all
this is just helping them the prolonging
it because no one's mad at them it's not
their fault and it's not like Oh
terrible production problems so they're
shut down because it's not going well
well you know this is just making people
want more than the speculation of the
because nothing can be done right now so
people are trying to snag reports it's
all just helping because I've noticed
I'm more excited no never because of the
fact that we haven't gotten a Marvel
property in a long time we don't know
when we will and this kind of thing gets
my conspiracy brain going because I sit
here going okay aside from casting which
could be affected by long time delay you
can just sit here and like crank out a
ton of scripts get like phase 10 through
20 going yeah and then just keep leaking
information ad infinitum until finally
were able to go back and make movies
again and by that point there will be so
much hype for what's the kind of like
they could never stop if they didn't
want to and it makes me wonder how the
rumor mill works because you know that
some of this stuff is being control
leaked from property Marvel itself
because they know people are excited and
they probably want to maintain some of
that I feel like this has a good chance
of happening because there's no way in
hell by now they're not aware that
everybody wants this you know yes I
think like Emily Blunt has been
approached a few times like she was the
one mainly courted for a while to be
Black Widow I believe that's a confirmed
fact that she might have even commented
on herself it's it's funny how all the
talk is primarily going to John
Krasinski it's like no we got a nail
down our Reed Richards first was I mean
we've talked about this Fantastic Four
stuff a few times we did a video with
cosmic Wonder weave and brought up you
know like what if they want John
Krasinski to actually direct this film
which I think would be cool we haven't
actually gotten that yet in this comic
book world we almost had it with Ben
Affleck directing Batman but obviously
that didn't pan out so be cool if we got
one way I don't know about the first one
though I don't know about like he should
direct the first Fantastic Four film and
star in it I mean he can do it he can
pull it off I'm sure he's had all this
work in the office he's a really funny
guy but he's become famous for directing
in terms of like deliberately paced
horror film and he's directing like some
episodes of The Office but it's not the
same thing as helming a Marvel Studios
film but I thats just me you know like
raising a little bit of a devil is a
heavy can't argue man when actuality I'm
sure he do a good job but I think what
Warren brought up is actually a really
solid point about the Marshall Lee
factor
more than to try to find the right
director first they look for the right
casting first and I would even explain a
little bit more of that ant-man
situation that occurred way back when
with Edgar Wright weirdly at least in
film talk smear but it seemed like
everyone was more excited about was
Edgar Wright directing and less about
Paul Rudd starring it we were all happy
with that no one was like screw this
we're all cool with that it was exciting
stuff but I think most of the joy was a
great doing this so that's why I think
it was such a big bummer and such a
discussion like Scott Derrickson leaving
dr. Strange's nowhere near as much of a
discussion as a girl I leave me a man
who is he know he already got his fur
right one you know bringing him her
shawl leave with blade I do think that
whether it be John Straczynski or
someone else that's a great point is
that they're looking for the star first
one and nowadays when I hear that like
I've come to accept that they've
probably met with every actor worth
their salt right now yeah that's what
I've come to do is marble yeah it's like
everyone's probably been in talks with
them and probably is frequently yeah
yeah which is neat which is neat but
yeah now I'm just never surprised yeah
this idea to of Emily Blunt not wanting
to do it because of multiple contracts
yes makes sense that's like the ultimate
jury like so how many times do we hear
about celebrity couples having to be
apart from their significant other
because of the line of work they're in
and they have a family together
what a dream gig that would be I would
imagine for them but at least appear to
get along really well you know we never
really know what goes on behind the
camera but they at least appear to get
along like immensely well they work
together a couple times now it seems
perfect yeah
opportunity in every respect yeah and
like movies like that especially if
they're just starring in it like they
can't work out together to get into the
marvel body shape and then they're also
able to probably have a lot of down time
to kick it because those movies things
like that are really waiting around a
lot see there's been a lot of family
time together if you want to do
preparing for the role I'm sure we'll
get them into the character like just by
virtue I think what's been nail this
down I think the fun will come into play
of who will play the thing and Human
Torch because yeah it seems like it's a
one two package if you get course in C
you're most likely gonna get Emily Blunt
well what would happen if we didn't
Krasinski and alexandra daddario Kristen
Stewart there's chemistry yeah this is
fun a lot of great points brought up
I've redeemed yourself warned yeah
Warren don't let it happen again yeah
you're the only one who reported that
the only one who ever misreported a
piece of the news and everyone freaked
out guys go check out our video that we
did with Warren where we did our
fantastic for Fantastic Four she just
called it that and it's so catchy
thorned cast but that's no one's typing
that in that's like it's so stylized no
one's ever gonna search it subscribe to
the cosmic wanted to give him to 550 K
so that way could finally give away
these damn video game systems
get yourself something it's taking up
space subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification will get
notified when we got a video up last but
not least let's end this with a alfred
benjamin threats the third beginning to
know this gentleman recently he once up
it up his own security company down the
road
um hey alfred ritscher little poem gregg
style looking for some counsel look at
the first letter and the vowel like
Bruce Wayne's Butler who helps up in the
cave not just in the manner but
possesses good manners I'm talking about
Alfred who has alas protected has ladies
hearts melted or is he gay yeah I don't
know I think he's straight I'm using the
shout out to tell y'all to keep a look
out for his future company dealing with
security cuz enough with the obscurity
and hypocrisy it's time to treat people
fairly aims to help people feel good
knows what it's like to be misunderstood
California's feeling much safer down in
the streets of Inglewood look out Chuck
Norris there's a new Texas Ranger cuz
he'll protect anyone from stranger
danger
he's not just a Power Ranger he's a
mother community Megazord ripped up his
own umbilical cord cleaned up a hoarders
hoard
never bored to death but death got bored
cuz his life as always restored that's
right Alfred is the ultimate protector
secret power is being a self resurrector
which makes him the ultimate Avenged
his last name is threats and you best
spent never to forget that [ __ ] or else
he'll end up in the grass of his death
you mess with you know and when he cares
about he's a good guy
love you Alfred
[Laughter]